tom alors comment raconter revenons un
peu en arrière
pourquoi êtes vous allé travailler à
hollywood est ce que finalement c'était
un peu écrit dans votre destin comment
ça c'est fait
non je crois que ce qui est très
important c'est que j'ai toujours eue
j'ai toujours eu une passion pour la
langue anglaise
j'ai vécu à cannes toute mon enfance et
par conséquent c'était les anglais car
c'étaient des amériques ils étaient des
gens qui arrivent et passer les vacances
des femmes extraordinaires qui repartait
à philadelphie où en californie c'était
c'est l exotisme ça vous éclairer mais
bien sûr
bien sûr c'était c'était l'invitation au
voyage
et puis je les fais le voyage je suis
allé à hollywood mais je n'ai jamais été
en tous les cas au début je n'étais pas
ce contrat avec un studio
c'est à dire une machine j'étais sous
contrat avec un homme qui était dérivée
de celle semer et c'était quelqu'un de
tout à fait extraordinaire dans
l'histoire du cinéma
on vous le située à 22 ans il était chef
de production la r k o à 25 il était
chef de production de la paramount et
quand je suis arrivé immédiatement et
j'étais prêt à écouter
j'étais prêt à retourner à l'école
étaient déjà jetés sur les chemins de
l'école j'étais prêt et j'ai écouté des
et la langue anglaise était capitale
pour moi hollywood ça a été d'abord ce
travail il m'a donné tout de suite deux
professeurs un professeur et de deux
jeunes garçons de mon âge qui me restait
toute la journée avec moi et ma femme
pour apprendre l'anglais courant l'armée
américain et puis un autre professeur
qui était alors une profession
professeur de diction de spa et j'ai
commencé il m'a dit il faut comme
oublier le film on ne va pas faire de
film avant six mois travaillés
shakespeare est-ce que c'était est-ce
que c'était l'habitude à hollywood c'est
à dire est ce que finalement parce que
en france est très rare qu'un producteur
vous prennent vous vous chambre et et
vous renvoie avec ce faire
good aussi parce que d ixelles stick
était un personnage très contradictoires
il a toujours combattu le système et en
même temps il en faisait partie
c'était c'était quoi quand vous êtes
arrivé à hollywood c'était quoi
hollywood s'était le mythe c'est elle et
c'était les personnages fabuleux qui
représente qui sont les symboles de
force de courage le charme de sexe
c'était tout ça est évidemment quand on
veut arrêter un peu impressionné ou pas
n'était évidemment énorme m vous vous
souvenez 7 vous étiez le
le ravissant jeune homme français qui a
débarqué à hollywood où j'étais autre
chose non c'était uniquement ça
seulement grâce à david ferrer smic
j'ai travaillé n'est ce pas et j'ai
appris mon métier vraiment à hollywood
parce que avec ce professeur
n'est ce pas j'ai écouté des
enregistrements des onze acteurs
américains les grands acteurs anglais
l'élan hackers américains s'étaient
c'était melvin d'agglo c'était john
barrymore est ce que vous les avez
rencontré ce que vous les avez connus
malines d'agglos bridge en bas il mort
était déjà mort mais je me souviens
encore je travaillais par exemple la
fameuse adresse de gettysburg n'est ce
pas qu'il est aussi connu que le loup et
l'agneau en amérique et c'était forces
américains traditionnels et puis avec
l'américain de shakespeare alors ça
c'était non non non non non si là aussi
tout est tout à fait différent c'est
commencer par la balle s'est retourné
aux sources et grâce à 2016 et je suis
retourné aux sources
alors j'écoutais des gens du
lance olivier alors j'entends qu'on
lance olivier laurence olivier c'est
made you tube ans nicolas privé tout
fait qu'une grippette
j'avais ça n'était pas si ce n'était pas
le sens mais écoutez justement c'est que
les références de les imiter
tous et en imitant tout le monde on
imite personnes on se cherche
je me cherchais et quand on se cherche
et bien on a des chances de se trouver
et se trouvait pour un acteur c'est quoi
c'est comprendre que le personnage vous
avez à jouer doit passer il doit devenir
c'est ça se trouvait semaines ce 3 ici
disait que le talent c'est la
personnalité
justement parlant de lens livier y
lisait il peut se mettre des perruques
des faunes et des barbes
c'est très amusant et c'est très bien
mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est lui c'est
laurence olivier qui est derrière
cellules qui m'intéresse c'est sa
personnalité et se trouvait c'est ça
est-ce que